but all right so new new ideas for the  content or where is it going from here  oh um I just started wife School  learning things to like  so  um the first episode was helping me pick  out better clothes a little bit  um and the second one is me learning how  to make a cake from scratch and  um how what did I cook it was it was  like stir-fry or something so it's like  the second episode is cooking next  episode  um what are we gonna do for episode  three I don't even remember oh they  wanted me to go on dates with guys but  get feedback from the guys like they're  not even gonna be on camera or like film  a date or anything but like just talk to  the guys and be like what did you think  of pearl so  um I could know like if I'm being  feminine I guess on dates if